[Applaudissements]
est ce que une personne à l'hygiène
douteuse s'avoue séduit ou scène nous
séduit pas les lumières vont s'activer
et y'a que jérôme anthony beaucoup les
personnes d'origine douteuse vous les
préférez propres je ne réponds pas c'est
pas au giro c'est un piège non j'aime
pas trop je remarque et elle l'a très
bien fait les gens qui chantent bonis
versés en le faisant mieux que les
autres c'est toujours étonnant la bieber
et houilles moment où vous avez parlé de
votre disparition pendant le prime de la
vérité vous souvenez est ce que vous
vous souvenez que pendant ce prime
il m'avait appelé par erreur oui pendant
votre disparition d'un mais non un truc
énorme à parts égales et même numéro que
le producteur des prime non qui je peux
dire ce que oui elle tel flot chose et
voilà les yeux peau est agressée avec
les mots je suis en train de chiffrer un
frérot
[Applaudissements]
je suis vraiment déçu que c'est à moi
que tu veux dire ça
pour celle du palais sans merci pour
l'accueil au bâton sympathique parce que
d'habitude quand on arrive dans un club
de vacances on a droit un collier de
fleurs ou un cocktail de bienvenue
moi j'ai eu la top de bienvenue c'est
jean michel maire dans les coulisses
vous dire que il a pensé moi là
aujourd'hui
ainsi avec son jeu quand je suis là le
vendredi c'est toujours sa part en
cacahuète les émissions